Chris Pratt gave a speech at the end of
you know as we were wrapping up um the
third movie and he gave this beautiful
speech and he was crying I didn't cry at
all he was crying profusely this is what
he does with Pratt this is their joke so
he was very much crying like a baby and
it was it was a little embarrassing and
in the speech what he get he was reading
off he went back and he looked up all of
the the articles that were written about
the Guardians before the movie came out
and he's quoting you know this is going
to be Marvel's first bomb this is and it
was just all this stuff about nobody
caring about these characters you know
wow and it was you cried what you cried
I I cried I got I got I got I got teary
I got teary I got a male very masculine
tear but I will admit I cried a lot it's
Zoe's speech it was really